now has the responsibility of Defending
Jamal Murray
you can smack the Murray another
three-pointer
Murray red
hot and Mike you didn't see this but
Jamal Murray just looked over there and
said bang
he was five of 17 through three quarters
he's five for five here in the fourth 14
points his reputation as a spectacular
playoff performer and he has shown that
here in the fourth quarter
so right Mike time and time again Big
Shots Out of the pick and roll getting
switched getting downhill knocking down
Big Time shots off of set plays
spectacular performance by Motors he got
that reputation in the bubble the last
time the Denver Nuggets were in the
conference final they overcame two 3-1
deficits in the first two rounds then
lost to Denver or lost to the Lakers in
the conference final he was magnificent
but the next year he tore his ACL missed
all of last season he's come back it's
been a bit of a slow process but he's